tutti ragazzi pervenute che sono video
sono farisei ed oggi siamo tornati sugli
simulator anche poi in realtà non si
chiama youtuber simulator ma si chiama
let's play simulator che sarebbe il
simulatore di let's play non l'avreste
mai detto nessuno l'avrebbe mai detto
in questo video che i ragazzi per chi
non lo conoscesse impersoni 1 youtuber
anche mal pettinato vedo il quale
obiettivo è quello di arrivare al
milione di iscritti
negli ultimi episodi ragazzi sono
arrivato a 500 mila iscritti e niente
adesso dopo due mesi visto che l'ho
fatto due mesi fa adesso cercherò di
arrivare da 500 mila al milione di
iscritti vincendo il gioco si fa questo
gioco non ci ai salvataggi mi sono
dovuto rifare tutto daccapo e arrivare
fino a 500.000 dove stava l'altra volta
porca [ __ ] io voglio arrivare al
milione allora il primo gameplay di oggi
e del gruppo
puoi giocare al nuovo simulatore i
simulatori di gru che bello facciamo
gioco del simulatore di gluck a me mi
piace a belle si è quella lì non è una
grotta rosso 18 garantisco io che quale
management 8.981 iscritti con un video
un gran contenuto tecnico accesso gioco
lo faccio io
solo per averlo fatto vedere in questo
momento vi do tempo ragazzi due minuti e
voglio vedere gli iscritti che arrivano
a quelli di pd pipe due minuti e non ho
mai visto un gioco così bello per l'amor
di dio lo farò più avanti succo mina
perché io adesso prendo spunto dai
giochi che fa bello sono arrivato a 526
mila iscritti fa chi è altro video che
ai ragazzi tra l'altro con man del
folklore e folklore no questo non lo
faccio il mi piace
ok non ho perso iscritti perfetto no
perché aiko mi sono dimenticato di dirvi
sta cosa o 50 per cento di possibilità
che un gameplay sia giusto o sbagliato
se questo gameplay e da fare e io premo
si guadagna iscritti se premono li perdo
questo qua secondo me da fare quindi
primo sì ma se invece non era da fare
verde istinti cazzo quanti cassano
perche 48 miei scritti beh ma sotto nato
che dietro lì prima o poi il tuo account
di east apparati stampa naram vi ha
aiutato un sacco più 2000 ma com è
perché mi faccio i sensi mentre sono al
cesso fatemi capire ai draft e
facciamolo se oggi sarah lane giusto per
carità di dio o chimica 27.000 stessi
però come li supera i 500mila torno
indietro to the video game mode ok sto
cazzo perso tutto 27 mila ragazzi siamo
tornati a 500 per l'amore di diverse
adesso sbaglio ne perde un sacco ma se
ne guadagno ne guadagno anche un sacco
di poe 50.000 sul meno guido 50 per
cento giusto
in teoria ragazzi basterebbe che ios e
cassis sei o sette volte di fila se
riuscissi a passa cosa avrei già vinto
presidenti vicepresidenti vol
facciamo presidenti vol vediamo non lo
facciamo non lo facciamo lo facciamo
così facendo si guardava 1 e si e 2 no
generates 1 lo faccio questo non è
residenti con questo è the grudge grazie
sito del cazzo 58100 20 e quasi verso la
fine lo sai del ris facciamo questo
andiamo su oroscopo.it metodo del sì e
del no il gioco dei tarocchi
mi sembra di essere mia nonna devo fà
devo fare il gioco bello per guadagnare
gli iscritti
ecco scopri il responso dei tarocchi
famiglia per la tua domanda devo fare il
gioco bello vuoi guadagnare gli iscritti
le carte prevedono il papa ma che cazzo
c'entra il mondo la ruota della fortuna
e il giudizio ma chi cazzo me ne frega
volevo sapere se sì o no oracolo sì o no
palla magica o questo era mi chiamo
ricordò più chiedere allora consiglio no
probabilmente sì stronzo forte
[ __ ] si è giustamente interfel a
interface sarebbe su inter sel questo lo
faccio secolo messina bello questo è più
belle sull'inter che io abbia mai
venduta mia vita a dio più di pai temi
final fantasy 10 anno fa final fantasy
10 ok eh sì non lo so che ci prova e vai
vai ti ho fame gameplay feinberg en
plein che merda sto gameplay la tua
recensione una merda
grazie fps no non lo faccio vi prego
basta
larry grotte senti gatto e dovrei farlo
questo gioco bello perché si chiama
harry potter non lo faccio
e meno male che non l'ho fatto big four
northern
temo rende studenti fanno capire è certo
che opera assistiti che sta crepando nel
gameplay
janos of trade questo perché questo è il
gioco di the house of the dead
be nice che culo sono tornati nuova 600
oracolo c'è bisogno di te dimissionatemi
dai un forze o un probabilmente jours
cazzo vuoi ti vengo a cercare tp a
schiaffi nel culo se il destino dice sì
e allora sì grazie a dio c'è il destino
che ci dice le cose è perfetto io ce che
max payne max games che sulla cena che
le bussole culo ragazzi siamo 700mila
non so come ma siamo a 700mila fermi
silent pil
credo che sia il pil italiano che
avrebbe comunque senso io direi di no
[ __ ] sapevo che non lo finirò maisto
gameplay lo sentono finirò mai zio
indiano ai mi hanno scritto mi ha
scritto il mio zio indiano perché sono
zio indiano o nipote sono io il tuo zio
durisch dall'india
ma chi cazzo fra mai sentito quando ami
dei soldi o ti butterò giù tutti i
server ma se bastardo adesso mi fa il
green fair sui miei server di minecraft
su convinto quale server
vabbè dai ti mandiamo dei soldi ma come
giornata fantastica e il credem e
migliore soprattutto zio frate arrivati
a questo punto ragazzi se faccio uno
sbaglio è devastante perché perdo tutto
però permessi
[Musica]
ci credo mai o ragazzi lui ci fossero
che è difficilissimo arrivare a sto
punto che fare una scelta azzeccata è
impossibile 800mila iscritti ragazzi
siamo quasi school boy jeremy kick ass e
ai today mai fare al dance school rocks
mio amico di scuola jeremic mamma gay ma
come era il tuo amico di scuola ti ha
chiesto di vederti l'ultimo giorno e non
posso andare a scuola perché io faccio
il gameplay è questo il futuro che bello
premier sun vuol dire che prendo il
posto di renzi altra poco top cry marco
e cazzo dovrebbe essere far cry solo che
stop cry che significa smettila di
piangere secondo me è no [ __ ] perché
sul 50 per cento porca eva non c'azzecca
mike sono niente o porca di quella
[ __ ] gamma incredibile di costruire
lo so cliccato non ho fatto un cappotto
grazie a dio ciao sono samantha se non
smetti di giocare a questi giochi
stupidi
vado via e lo so se a te non piace
youtube a te piace un altro you quindi
vai e cerca il tuo posto nel mondo si a
questi si rafforza 6 di ozil for kids
dio quanto ti adorato 173 ragazzi se
riesco ad azzeccarne due di fila ho
vinto due di fila per me no no aspetta
ora scopo oroscopo spera di sì era
grazie attiva per l'aj speriamo di si io
spero di sì
le carceri di spostare spera di sì vabbè
è superata una lezione definito tutto
nell'anno vero zio grande sfera di fitto
a non si si diane secolo che arriva
900.000 dzeko la maledizione azzecca c'è
molto meno iscritti in teoria mi ha
mandato una mail il mio gatto a domestic
ami di più fa cosa vuoi che vivi sul mio
monitor deficiente o ten sexy
videogiochi ott in sexy su youtube fanno
un botto quindi si 978 stalla altri
quattro ragazze il finale e ci azzecco
ho vinto quando c'erano le verifiche a
crocette quando c'è davvero falso vero
falso quando mettevo due o tre veri
indice di seguito poi dicevo cazzo
quando sono troppi i veri allora
mettiamo un falso ok questa la mia
geniale metodo di studio e sarà anche
quello di qualcuno di voi sono convinto
siccome erano tutti si per adesso gli
direi no e infatti cazzo quanto funziona
c'è un motivo se sono stato promosso per
l'amor di dio chi ha un gard scroll
bolivian che sarebbe di ethos cross
oblivion sono un po diverso niente se ne
prendo 64.000 ho vinto quindi potrei
ancora vincere sì sì sì
[Musica]
cazzo cazzo 61 è vero non ci credo mai
ho avuto la reaction che era un misto
tra contentezza e delusione perché è un
sì però non sono arrivate milione per
pochissimo tipo scema ma davvero cook
umbra che sarebbe penombra no vai vai
page due quello di prima era un no
quindi statisticamente parlando questo
deve essere un sì
[Musica]
che bella giornata per youtube
mio dio milione e 62 mila iscritti
fantastico
[Musica]
minchia che che gasamento incredibile
l'hai fatta se il miglior youtuber nel
mondo o milioni di iscritti il livello
dio è una donna
no sono dio vorrà a una cosa sola cosa
la tua ragazza ti ha lasciato
mi dispiace a me che cazzo me ne frega a
me che ciò i big money per ragazzi spero
che video vi sia piaciuto o un miliardo
di iscritti per questa cosa perché mio
dio se vi è piaciuto il dosso quel
momento è non mi piace anche la pagina
di facebook e come dirlo tornando
iniziale essere si disconosce diavolo
prossimo video ragazzi